the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023
grandchester your Champion follow the St
Louis chess club's twitch and YouTube
channels to tune in to live coverage of
the 2023 sinkfield cup November 21st to
December 1st to find
out